carrusel de las artes
a maría carolina piña
[Música]
bienvenidos a esta nueva entrega de
carrusel de las artes muy complacida de
que estén en nuestra sintonía y hoy les
tenemos un programa que saldrá de los
senderos del arte convencional para ver
otras formas de creación
descubriremos lo que en francia se
conoce como artes modestas a través de
un museo único el miami de la ciudad de
sete una institución que en 20 años de
actividad se ha encargado de rescatar
objetos del arte popular folclórico o
publicitario el arte urbano es otro
protagonista en nuestro programa hoy
conoceremos el trabajo colorido de m&g
la bomba por las calles de parís en
nuestro bloque de cine francés nos
elevaremos a lo alto de la emblemática
torre de parís con la cinta efe y
visitaremos espacios subterráneos en el
hombre de la cava
conoceremos a un cantante que hace un
llamado a bajar el ritmo y a vivir más
humana y lentamente gael fog estará con
nosotros en nuestra crónica musical
[Música]
comenzamos a este carrusel en la ciudad
de sete en el sur de francia allá se
encuentra un museo muy particular el
museo internacional de artes modestas el
miami que acaba de cumplir 20 años de
existencia y ustedes se preguntarán qué
son esas artes modestas es lo que nos
explicó el fundador de este museo vamos
allá de la mano de melissa barra
[Música]
mira
el me ames como un gustoso gabinete de
curiosidades a orillas del mediterráneo
en el puerto de seth se encuentra este
museo internacional de arte modesto
único en su estilo viejos juguetes
baratijas y figuritas artesanales o
industriales se mezclan con pinturas
esculturas e instalaciones de artistas
llamados marginales creaciones que no se
exponen en grandes museos o galerías
como lo explica el artista y fundador
del miami hervé di rosa
y aquí necesitamos a tener un punto de
vista distinto mostramos artistas y
obras que no se ven en ningún otro lado
hoy en día eso significa ser muy audaz
hace fondo
y rosa acuñó el término de arte modesto
en los años 90 en oposición al elitismo
comercial reinante en el mundo del arte
contemporáneo en el miami cobran valor
artístico objetos a primera vista
banales
[Música]
ya sea una obra como el lugar de césar o
un juguete gratis dentro de un huevo de
chocolate para mí ambos son esculturas
que
es un proyecto muy amplio que reposa en
tres valores fundamentales rescatar
artistas y artesanos desconocidos como
por ejemplo los que confeccionaron
productos de juguetes mostrar obras
exigentes a un público que no
necesariamente conoce el arte
contemporáneo y tener la plena libertad
de escoger nuestra identidad
[Música]
él me ama cumplió 20 años de existencia
en noviembre pasado por lo que organiza
hasta 2022 una exposición denominada
psico delicia
[Música]
y en cuenta que desde los años 30
artistas franceses ya realizaban
experiencias mentales intentando
sobrepasar la conciencia con o sin
drogas de hecho los afiches de
conciertos organizados en california en
los años 60 con grupos psicodélicos
estuvieron muy influenciado por la
cultura europea y el estilo
pinturas del célebre aunque millones se
exponen junto a las de el confidencial
ser ix porque como dice de rosa el miami
no es un espacio de contracultura no de
nosotros somos un punto de encuentro y
seguimos simulando después de 21 años
[Música]
gracias melisa barra y del arte modesto
vamos al arte urbano hace poco les
ofrecíamos un programa completamente
dedicado al street art en parís hoy los
invito a conocer un artista que se
expresa en las calles su nombre es m g
la bomba y lo conocimos en la capital
francesa
[Música]
para mg la bomba el soporte para pintar
puede ser cualquier rincón es uno de
esos artistas urbanos activos en las
calles de la región de parís me
llamo guión pero me conocen como m&g o
la bomba me dedico al graffiti desde
hace 25 años pero dibujo desde que era
muy pequeño el dibujo y el arte han sido
una terapia para mí comencé en el arte
urbano con la muchos de forma ilegal
ella fue la escuela para luego saltar
hacia la pintura en las galerías mi
objetivo es poner color por donde pasó
por estas calles y espacios que a veces
son morosos
[Música]
en el medio me conoce por mi firma la
bomba un pequeño personaje en forma de
aerosol que siempre colocó en mis obras
con la bomba me ha acompañado desde que
comencé a pintar en la calle se desvía
ferré mi pintura en las letras que son
las bases de grafitis
en mucha perspectiva trampantojos y
mucho trabajo de los detalles en sobras
hoy en día m g la bomba trabaja para
galerías y particulares pero pintar en
la calle sigue siendo una pasión con
enjuagues después sin viento se puede
trabajar pero respetando los lugares y a
las personas que viven allí al principio
el arte urbano sufrió de una imagen
negativa asociada al vandalismo o la
degradación yo pienso que es una forma
de arte espontánea propia de la calle
así que responde a una necesidad de
expresión de decir estamos vivos y ese
grito puede tomar formas muy bellas
del monje
muchas de las pinturas dmg la bomba
tienen sombras pero siempre hay un rayo
de luz una fase de mi vida no siempre ha
sido fácil y eso se refleja en mis
pinturas hay muchos gris sombras pero
también hay luz como pasa en la vida no
todo es bueno o malo negro a blancos
incluso en mis pinturas más oscuras
siempre hay un punto de los que nos
invita a ir hacia ella durante mucho
tiempo fue un elemento que utilicé de
inconsciente necesita muchos años para
entenderlo son los que serían aplicados
y cultura
[Música]
y a continuación la cartelera del cine
francés en la que encontramos entre
otros la historia de uno de los
monumentos más icónicos del mundo y del
ingeniero francés que le regaló su
apellido para la posteridad nos amplía
asvel lópez
[Música]
se estrena en las salas de cine
francesas el esperado biopic del
ingeniero gustave eiffel padre de la
torre emblemática de parís
y tú
4 metros
la película de martin volumen cuenta la
aventura detrás de la construcción de la
torre eiffel a finales del siglo 19 un
proyecto de ingeniería colosal y
peligroso que suscitó una gran polémica
en su época
la cinta pone de trasfondo otro
escándalo el del romance prohibido entre
gustavo eiffel protagonizado por román
de obi y una adolescente de la burguesía
encarnada por la actriz emma mackay un
amorío que marcará el futuro del
monumento parisino
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en el hombre de la cava un misterioso
desconocido protagonizado por falso que
se adquiere una bodega en la planta baja
de un edificio parisino y poco a poco
los vecinos empiezan a sospechar que se
trata de un antisemita negacionista cuya
influencia empieza a extenderse a los
demás residentes
en este thriller psicológico de philippe
le guay el conspiracionismo se convierte
en el monstruo que pondrá en peligro a
toda una familia
an
y llegó la hora de nuestra crónica
musical y para ello ya está en el
estudio con nosotros natale olivares
hola natalia hola maría carolina que tal
bien y bueno como siempre en la crónica
musical tú nos presentas un artista de
la escena musical francesa que vamos a
descubrir ya mismo
ya estamos en el gran control un lugar
multicultural cerca de la guerra del yom
aquí antes habían trenes que repartía el
correo en el barrio 12 de la capital y
aquí mismo está ya el fax que nos recibe
para hablar de su nuevo disco que se
llama el agua de la piel de la popa en
ese disco hay una canción que se llama
renunciar
[Música]
y en sus casos
no creo que renunciar significa en mi
caso dejar de querer complacer a toda
costa y lograr ser más simple más
sensato como vivir el momento presente
en el día a día a mi propio ritmo y
asumir nuestro ritmo
tú
es artista que escuchamos es ya el
fortín nos invita a
abandonar ese ritmo desenfrenado de
nuestras vidas y lo hace ese mensaje con
una vaca exactamente quién más simple
que más lento que más tranquilo que una
vaca para que el fuego fue una evidencia
tener que elegir como protagonista a una
vaca francesa del campo francés ella se
ama y se llama the right list directora
y realmente creo que lo supo enamorar
mi historia con las vacas es algo viejo
porque mi padre es campesino y tenía 60
vacas lecheras ellas fueron mi primer
público como no me atreví a cantar
delante de mis padres les tocaba a ellas
con mi pequeña guitarra la vaca tiene
algo muy tierno en la mirada como si
fuera savia puedes insultarla y nunca se
enoja le puedes decir que la amas y no
se moverá y esta canción renault ser es
una declaración de amor lo asumo de
hecho me dieron ganas de abrazar la vaca
de verdad bueno casi
sí
aquí
hoy no sé con una vaca que parece que es
una verdadera historia de amor entre la
sierra y christie y el folk el folk que
firma ese disco en curso luego el apoel
agua de la piel un disco militante
militar por una vida mejor por la
protección de la naturaleza y ya él fue
entrega un mensaje fuerte a actuar y ya
y no quedarse inmóvil frente a la
emergencia climática
intento crear cosas bellas sin insultar
a la gente tratando de concienciar la y
me incluyo a mí mi papel es crear
canciones y melodías poniendo todo el
corazón busco que la gente no se quede
encerrada en su comodidad que reaccione
que actúe que reaccione como me sucede a
mí cuando toco cuando escribo o cuando
compongo
[Música]
el título descansaba
gracias natal olivares por presentarnos
a este cantante gael fue justamente
vamos a terminar este carrusel como una
de sus canciones si veis que va
agradeciéndoles por su amable sintonía
los dejamos entonces con gael facme
archivo cut agua
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y